I first of all very nice to be here
thanks for the invitation and I will
start with apologizing you because I'll
probably have not enough time to cover
this topic it's very broad and I have to
confess that I decided to talk about
things that I find interesting and maybe
you'll find something interesting in
that as well
so first I will introduce myself I'm by
professional physicist I did my PhD in
theoretical physics and University of
Warsaw then I worked in academia in
research in Poland abroad and then I
moved as many of my colleagues to data
science so many physicists work as data
scientists and currently I work in
Warsaw at Gibson's AI but after work I'm
I like to write songs I'm a songwriter
singer and I never thought that these
two activities of mine will have a
common space where I can talk about them
together but actually artificial
intelligence and it doesn't turn out to
be a possibility for that so the topic
is very broad and as we know tomorrow
Jim Coggan will talk about I think
neurons aesthetics I don't know the
other days of the his his talk but there
and there's a number of art projects or
art artificial intelligence related
projects that are being developed and
you can google that you I don't want to
talk about site transfer I'm not going
to talk about guns I don't have
experience in that and I'm I can
recommend you googling and searching and
we can talk about AI as being new means
of artistic expression and we can use AI
and art education or education in
general and we I think a very good idea
would be for artists to talk about
artificial intelligence to communicate
to the society well about what
artificial intelligence can bring but
I'm also interested in more general
questions so slightly different
questions about creativity because I
like doing stuff without creating stuff
I don't know how about you but I guess
all of you have been involved somehow in
creative processes I don't know if you
had a chance to analyze them or how they
are being processed but whenever we are
talking about creativity
the art and artificial intelligence I
think it's good idea to define what we
understand by that and I think art is
not creativity because for example we
talk about kids being creative and
that's true they are very playful but
somehow we do not display their art
works in Tate Modern Art in Britain so
not everything not every random
combination is artistic always
interesting artist I think more deeper
thing so I would like to touch a little
bit about creativity and I'm interested
in how we could perhaps quite a
characterize creativity as a
computational problem okay so from the
perspective of data science and machine
learning but I'm gonna talk about two
things today so first thing and which
was a motivation to come here to PI data
is a result of a rock art hackathon
organized this year by national museum
in warsaw and of course i'm forgot to
mention that on a daily basis as a data
data scientist I work in Python
obviously so that's why I'm PI data so
I'm gonna talk about that and then I'll
try to maybe not give you any definite
answers but hopefully give you some
interesting open questions about how we
can look at the creative processes
okay so hack art maybe some of you heard
about it maybe some of you have been
there it was a hackathon organized by
two ladies of Augusta and Sylvia to
Kefka at national museum in warsaw and
the idea was very cool he was to bring
to very distant concept so concept of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence new technologies and art
and art history and put them together
and work one for the other and they
presented us with a number of challenges
and they gave us a data set of 200
images of paintings and sculptures and
there were 40 participants it was only
in the end of May and also and my team
we called ourselves team vs vs from data
science that was a temporary name but it
remained and we were all out of course
Cockerill miok pathogen gene appeared
media on me and some of us work or
collaborated with him since I am
so we actually started we went there to
the hackathon with completely different
idea it was about recognizing
doppelgangers on images but it turned
out that Google did something all right
like that so we had to find for a
different idea and what we did was to
target a specific group target group
from museum kids and families and we
created a game in a form of web app we
call it museum treasures and when
working on it and defining this game we
focus on three specific questions so how
to encourage families to come with kids
to the museum how to make the visit in
the museum fun and I want to stress that
because in this approach artificial
intelligence was a tool it was not a
central actor it was not the aim was not
to show off the possibilities of AI it
is the aim was to solve the problem to
attract kids and families to the museum
okay and we had just two days for that
so what we so the game missing treasures
is based on the observation that kids
like to find things they like to search
things for hidden things for hidden
treasures so we based on data resolution
and the idea is that the game shows you
a number of categories from which you
can choose you choose the category and
you search for objects of that category
in the museum what are these objects so
we show you fragments of of paintings
and your task is to find the paintings
from which those fragments were taken so
imagine you are a kid you are given a
category you choose the category animal
and you have I know ten fragments
showing dogs horses care cats and we
give you all the information about in
which room the painting is located the
rooms are big so there are many
paintings in one room so you really have
to go there you have to look at the
paintings you have to find the fragment
and the simplest version of the game is
without verification the more advanced
would be with verification how does it
work so basically you have a set
you need a set of fragments so you need
to sample from some dictionary of
fragments and we were given a data set
of images so that's your starting point
then you have to convert it into a
dictionary of fragments of given
category of meta meta category and then
perhaps apply some automated or
supervised filtering methods and then at
the end this is sent to the application
and the user sees a set of categories
chooses one category and see the sampled
specific number of fragments so the AI
part comes here in helping us
translating the set of images into the
dictionary of fragments and how we do
that we do that with object detection so
that's one of the non deep learning
models that given the image it will
recognize specific categories on an
image and draw bounding boxes on the
image giving also the probability so the
accuracy accuracy telling you what that
is sure not sure that this is the the
case okay so this is a schematic way of
how object writing addiction works what
were the issues the issue here was that
our dataset was very small only 200
images but more importantly we didn't
have any labels for the for the data set
so we didn't have any grandchildren in
boxes and a more
moreover I mean that the dingiest was
small and we were not sure whether we
would have enough like elements of each
category that we would like to have and
of course wrong predictions what to do
with them okay given the model I mean it
will not be 100% performing so our
approach was at that point during the
hackathon to use already trained model
from Google vision IP and the model was
faster or CNN type it had more than 500
categories and we passed the entire
dataset through the model of course you
may ask do we want to do that online or
offline and in this scenario it is
enough to do this all
so you take entire data set you send it
to the model and you prepare the
predictions offline of course it can be
done online you can build an app which
will make predictions online but that
was not necessary here and what was
necessary to make sure that the
predictions are good quality because we
are working with kids and if you present
and if you make mistake and tell the
kids that it has to look for a cat and
you show it him or her I don't know a
car I mean the kid might be disappointed
and we don't want that so really quality
is important so for the demonstration
during the hackathon we had to ourselves
go through the predictions and see how
the model worked okay and I showed it
them all but you can go to one of the
blog posts either a tip sensei I blog or
medium about ragazza from the museum she
created a nice blog about new
technologies and museum so the
description of this idea and the project
is there with the links to the github
and the demo but I wanted to tell you
what happened next
so we want the first place in the
hackathon and then we agreed to do a
pillow touch and for the pillow - so we
really really wanted to have kids coming
to the museum and checking out this idea
and for the pillow - we were given a new
set of images from the galleries of 19th
century these were like 260 images and
it again turned out that of course the
model detects many categories there but
sometimes you have like a category of I
don't know a fish and there are only
three fishes so you cannot use this
category to sample from it in the app
and that's why we created meta
categories and for example body parts is
a collection of more specific categories
animals is also another meta categories
so it was not done out to me
automatically but what you wanted to do
it it was to also introduce filtering
and this is what we are working on now
so filtering the images with high
probability bounding boxes filtering the
image the fragments
that are big enough and so on so there
is a set of ideas that for the filters
next thing is the verification I told
you that the the basic idea of the game
was assuming that we don't have a
verification method automatic
verification but we can use that we can
do that with introducing metadata of the
painting for example as the kid to
introduce the year of the painting and
another idea here is also to perhaps
introduce hints so we may use RTI model
that generates descriptions for images
and try to do that with with our images
of paintings however the most important
part is other predictions and so we took
the new data set we pass it through them
through the model and you can see that
sometimes it works nicely sometimes not
so the upper row shows you the images
with some specific categories identified
there and you can see the first left is
microphone that raises my suspicious
suspicion immediately it's not a
microphone now interesting examples with
sculpture because sculpture sometimes
works nicely like on the second left
image but the third one is not and said
I think it's an interesting observation
that the modeler really has to do a very
difficult task here because imagine that
a painting is already a presentation of
reality and then within a pain think you
have another representation of reality
as sculpture so how the model can
distinguish between the person in the
painting or sculpture in the painting so
that might be very difficult table were
it's fine furniture yes the lower row
represents already the fragments for
some meta categories so animal like a
nice dog not the second one animal
that's a bit strange well it's a human
the third one is plant so probably it's
a flower the fourth one is interesting
because the style of the painting is
very strong here it's very different
from the image however still that the
model was able to recognize a person
there now architecture and food is also
very into
thing like especially food I think that
might have been a hand or a chicken I
don't know but this this is a well not
so how to improve that of course you can
look for a better model or you can
really train your your own model to have
more control and our one of our ideas
here that is not yet done but it's the
idea for experiment it's a really used
style transfer as a method of for data
augmentation because I I had this idea
before when working on one of this
year's data Science Bowl problem with no
detecting nuclei it didn't work it
didn't help but here data augmentation
with site transfer actually you might be
working because what we can do we can
choose some object detection model
download weights download the the data
set perhaps choose a subset with
specific categories there and pass it
through a site transfer offline with a
style from for example the 19th century
paintings and then continue training on
that that subset to see if it helps with
very difficult difficult objects so
that's that's our idea and that's what's
happening now in terms that we are
preparing the code we are working on
some filtering methods we have a
refining the predictions we need to have
some improvement in front end but we are
planning to really have a test in Museum
so I hope in the near future I will be
able to invite you all to the museum to
test test the game and if you'd like to
read more please go to the blog post so
that's the first part of the
intersection of art and AI the second
part is more I think higher level and as
I told you before I'm not going to give
you like definite answers but I would
like to show you some observations so
probably all of you have been involved
in some creative processes but maybe not
analyze creativity as a process itself
but what we know is that creativity
involves exploration randomness
playfulness
and there is no stress there is no space
for stress so there should be a space
for free exploration without judgments
so it's a space where we can make
mistakes and nobody is judging us
contrary to their face of execution when
once we have an idea and we need to
execute it and we need to develop it
then really need really need discipline
there was a nice talk about creativity
by John Cleese on YouTube I don't know
if it's still there but if there is any
are interested I can recommend it now
people thought about creative process
like long time before and this this
representation was done by hermann von
helmholtz
and Henri Poincare so in creative
process I mean you can actually identify
very Universal stages and this comes
from people who are working arts science
and doesn't matter ok you have a stage
of saturation you have a stage of
incubation and illumination sometimes we
add to this a verification now
saturation is when you define the
problem you gather information
everything you can about the problem you
dig in into the problem ok
you can compare it to the creation of
some kind of data set of experiences
related to the task now later you have a
stage of incubation which is
subconscious and it's unpredictable in
terms of time it's not variety that
you're gonna find a solution of a
problem that you're gonna find and a
brilliant idea but when it when you find
it it usually comes as a ha moment a
moment of elimination and that's a
signal from subconscious to conscious
ok so it may find you when you are
walking home from grocery store and
finally you know I found the idea later
on you may verify it at home this
happens for example in scientific
discovery when you have an idea and you
need to check some additional
calculations and so on but this is a
very general stage now an example from
song writing maybe some writing is not
the easiest way of talking about
creativity because it's quite complex
process but I like writing songs so I'll
give you a simple
example now I imagine you have to write
a song about poor burns story related
some building and a story from a city
it's actually from my hometown so I was
working on that I was I had a nice idea
for the chorus and I was digging into
the reading stories related to that
building to that particular history and
then I left it aside because I didn't
have a idea for the first verse so I
left it aside and in the meantime in my
workplace actually I put on a display
one of the images related to the story
and it was there for weeks and at some
point I came with the idea of first
verse which actually if you can read it
is about the bright light so actually it
resembles the image that I was using to
enhance it in the meantime now of course
it's shining example doesn't mean much
you can look at process of songwriting
creating lyrics from AI perspective and
there are many projects that do that
quick Google search shows you this
project and what they did they used LSD
aims for generating lyrics and they say
that what you need in the model is to
see the word or phrase and the model
will generate a lyrics in a style of a
specific artist so yeah that's not not
something maybe unexpected but if you
write as songwriters how they do work on
songs and creation of lyrics it's
actually a deeper process because it's
not on the layer of lyrics while lyrics
is the end product yes there is a very
good book on writing lyrics and there is
a very good very popular exercise on
creative writing I can recommend it to
you
it's called object writing and it's a
very short exercise that it's creative
and the idea is that you take a seed
word you can take it from a dictionary
you can take it from a website object
writing calm
run by Pat Patterson the author of the
book and then what you have to do is to
generate a scenario inspired by the word
so I tell you for example coffee and
things that appear so you create a
stream of consciousness the stream of
associations there's a very crucial
assumption here that you have to stay
stands about so you create you generate
a world around that concept and you stay
close to your experiences related to the
senses that's also important from the
perspective of the lyrics because senses
and these experiment sexual experiences
are something that everyone can relate
to
that's why they are very powerful in the
lyrics now you do that for 10 minutes
only and this is not more not less and
the purpose of this exercise is to make
it easier to you to dig into and to dive
into your imaginations and easily
generate the world's and I would like to
see something like that some kind of
experiment like that
in the domain of machine learning
because the end product is the same as
the project from the previous slide but
you can see that the process itself is
different it's image based or sensual
based it's the the lyrics is the upper
layer here and maybe you heard about
this this is a project that was
announced of the products announced this
week Promethean AI and it's a product
from a game industry which is a tool for
artists that general generates templates
of world of course it's not as as good
as humans but the aim of this is to
generate like the the template on which
you can all work okay so in a sense it's
also we see that these things have
started to happen in in the domain of
MMA I okay but coming back to the
creative process and trying to
understand it
and I would like to dig into it because
I would like to understand better human
creative process and I think that
machine learning experiments can perhaps
help help us doing that so we had a
situation we have incubation and
illumination and what is interesting is
the stage going from incubation to
elimination because if you go from
subconscious to conscious then the
signal must be very strong
that's one observation and as a
physicist when I hear about that I think
maybe there are some resonant effect
that promotes really enhances some
specific signal the other observation is
that once you find the good the one idea
you have this gut feeling that this is
the one and you do not search more so
perhaps from the computer from the
physical process you've had some found
some minimum or you've been rewarded and
also that there is no guarantee that
you're gonna find the solution so it's
like finding a minimum maybe you will
not find a minimum so maybe there's some
kind of multi-dimensional space and
there is no guarantee that you find a
final solution and there are multiple
probably good solutions so there is no
guarantee that there is just one
solution to your task okay so maybe we
could think about this also in terms of
a game and in terms of for example
reinforcement learning where you have
agent playing in the environment sending
actions and interesting rewards maybe
the the brain or this is a process that
somehow is kind of like a game but if
it's a like a game then the question is
what is the environment and what is
being rewarded okay so the environment
could be brought for for instance the
space of concepts or our experiences or
our memory but if you have a space then
we would need we need also concept of
the proximity or the measure of the
distance now if you treat the memory
like a huge database of experiences than
perhaps proximity is related to
coherence of various concepts okay now
the other thing what is being rewarded
often we say that creative process of
creative ideas are the ones that bring
very
and things together that is something
that is unexpected okay but we often say
well we often see that these ideas that
the best ones are the simple ones there
is also a concept of familiarity and I
will give you maybe example in a moment
and what I think it's important is that
not every random combination of two
distant concepts is is interesting so
it's not only about exploring the space
and finding putting distant things
together so I'll just give you a tiny
example here so imagine that you have a
task of writing a song that is very
short and catchy but the subject is
transparency and public information so
this is the real-life experience I I did
this so I sometimes support one of the
NGOs in Poland and they work with these
topics so as you can imagine this is not
the most romantic topic for a song but
anyway we managed I managed to it was a
songwriting challenge for me but the
solution was that I wrote a short song
based on tongue twisters and now we may
ask what is the relation been turned
from twisters and you may think that
these two things are very decent
concepts so how you bring them together
and why this is a good solution and it
turns out that there is a actually
multiple paths how you can connect these
two ideas they're very dissonant yes but
you can bring a mutual context for them
to interact together and there's also a
sense of familiarity for the tongue
twisters because this is something that
everyone heard of okay so I think this
is my last slide showing you that from
one concept you can go to another one
which is very different multiple ways
and perhaps this is something that could
be one of the things that is being
rewarded in such processes that if you
have
you search for a random leaf for a very
distant concept and then you try to link
those concepts and if you think in terms
of machine learning models imagine
they'll have a model that it's object
detection and you have thousands of
categories and you can ask okay which
categories are closer to each other in
the space of categories in the space of
representations and on that you you may
search well on that basis you could
perhaps design a simple experiment that
could mimic this or that could represent
this these ideas thank you very much
[Applause]